mommy yes yeah
yeah nothing shuts down a sexy selfie
moment like your kid running in the room
and that's just what happened to cardi b
on thursday night
the [ __ ] rapper shared this sultry clip
on instagram
that's the 28 year old showing off her
curve-hugging corset
long straight hair with green highlights
giving those
bedroom eyes to the camera only to have
her two-year-old daughter culture who
she shares with rapper offset
walk right into the room asking for her
mommy
mommy yes yeah
cardi goes from sexy mama to mommy mode
in a matter of nanoseconds mommy
yes yeah the grammy winner captioned the
clip quote
i can't even be sexy in peace she's so
cute i love her
of course under quaran times nothing is
as relatable as having your kids crash
your moment
hi everyone in california it's kim
kardashian west and i just wanted to
talk to you and north west back
in april north straight up inserted
herself in kim kardashian's stay-at-home
psa
i know that can you not jump on the bed
give me like two seconds to seriously do
this
and the seven-year-old wouldn't leave
her mom alone while she filmed a makeup
tutorial
i'm hiding in the guest room you guys
i'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
classic north can i please just do my
little tutorial i
i it's all i want to do is one little
fun thing for myself
in april one of chris hemsworth's twins
was right there
ready to interrupt his interview with an
australian radio station
it's pretty unique and special it's my
kids in the background
and just like that his kiddo was right
in frame
you can't always sort of you know plan
it that way tina fey's eight-year-old
daughter penelope
totally hijacked her interview on late
night with seth meyers in may
yes can i help you
i'm sorry you're not making sound what
i'm
yes hello hello we're taping a
television program now do you need
something
i i did the um interactive i
clicked for her entry
then there was jason bateman whose
daughter maple didn't exactly walk in
the room when he was having an interview
with jimmy kimmel but
well just watch it for yourself oh there
goes maple and while jimmy fallon filmed
the tonight show at home
amid quarantine his daughters winnie and
franny
crashed his virtual interview with ethan
hawk comes out
august 9th are you kids interrupting the
interview
they're running don't you come over here
do not come over here
yeah both of you guys are out of here
right now